Diego had only just found this footing
when it gave out underneath him again
crashing to the ground he threw both
arms over his head just in time to
protect his skull from the rain of
Boulders that came down past him they
grazed his arms and Jarred painfully
against his muscles but it was better
than having them hit him in the head
without a moment to spare Diego got
straight up to his feet and continued
running back down the trail he had been
trying to follow the ground shifted and
lurched in all directions under him
threatening to throw off his balance at
any moment having lived in Chile his
whole life he had gotten used to
earthquakes but he had never been in the
center of one like this the problem was
that the trail he had been following to
get up here was disappearing fast as the
dust swirled into the air and boulders
Landing all around him he just had to
keep running in this direction and hope
for the best there weren't any other
options but suddenly he found himself
running uphill stumbling forwards Diego
tried desperately to get his bearings he
had spent the previous three hours
hiking up the mountains so how was it
that now that he had turned around and
gone back he was still going uphill it
was almost as if the ground was changing
shape beneath him as he ran dust filled
his lungs as he tried to wipe it away
from his burning eyes yes the ground was
definitely going uphill but it felt
almost as if it was lifting itself up
beneath him as if some tectonic plates
were grinding together creating a new
Mountain beneath his feet Diego lurched
unsteadily and grabbed the nearest rock
to keep his balance feeling the ground
lifting higher and higher beneath him
then all of a sudden the cloud of dust
broke and he was in fresh air Rising
ever higher into the sky the Andes
Mountains stabbed out of the clouds all
around him cutting beautiful shapes
across the Horizon he felt his own
Mountain steadily growing taller than
any of them he dropped down on all
floors and clutched at the ground in
Terror as he tried his best to take in
the shape of what he was now standing
upon how far would you go to prevent a
cosmic level disaster it's one thing to
save your friends and family from an
armed murderer it's another thing to
fight for your country in a world war we
can even just about imagine what it
means to fight for our planet to save
our species from climate change to save
our world from a meteorite but what
would a cosmic disaster look like a
Calamity is so Broad in scale that it
surpasses our ability to even perceive
the threat we could Point our most
advanced telescope into deep space and
look straight down the middle of it and
never know it was even there and if that
threat was not simply to the survival of
humanity or planet Earth but to the
survival of existence itself how far
would we go to prove invented what cruel
and inhumane measures would you take to
have such a threat or better yet how
many people would you kill to save the
world this debate is Raging right now as
you sit here and watch this video not
among the foundation but between two
scps so Grand in scale and so advanced
in nature that the foundation has no
option but to sit and listen as the pair
debate what to do with the human race
scp-4568-1 was not difficult to discover
once it started moving in fact it was
almost impossible to ignore earthquakes
have been tearing across South America
for centuries destroying homes taking
the lives of innocent people and
fundamentally changing the shape of our
planet itself what most people do not
realize however is that the fault line
running through the Andes mountain range
has actually largely been dormant during
this period the source of the
earthquakes has come from something far
more mysterious our innocent hiker Diego
had been spending the week walking among
the Andes when the earthquake struck you
would be forgiven for assuming as Diego
did that the ground Rising beneath his
feet was a new Mountain forming as the
tectonic plates clashed together but the
Staggering reality of the situation was
that he found himself hiking along the
back of
scp-4568-1 as the creature raised its
head into the air Diego saw the head of
a serpent lifting several kilometers
away from him its body stretched and
wound its way through the mountain range
filling the valleys and running beneath
his feet the scale of
scp-4568-1 is hard to convey measuring
over 500 kilometers in length this
serpent is longer than most U.S states
with a 20 kilometer width standing on
the back of it quite literally feels
like standing on a mountain range for
context The Horizon at sea level is
about 4 4.8 kilometers away so multiply
that by 4 and you'll get a sense of just
how wide this thing is even small
movements from this SCP are enough to
trigger continent-wide earthquakes with
tremors being felt all the way around
the world upon the initial discovery of
this SCP the foundation was unable to
determine why it remains dormant for
such long periods and seems to only
awaken sporadically and for brief
periods of time that was until
scp-4568-2 was discovered it is little
wonder that the second serpent took so
long to be found its body is comprised
almost entirely of water sand algae and
steam it does not show up on Sonar scans
and is incredibly difficult to detect in
the water even visually its form is
Loosely defined while stormant with
broadly similar measurements to
scp-4568-1 this serpent roams the South
Pacific Ocean any Marine creature that
swim into the scp's body find themselves
undergoing beneficial mutations crabs
grow extra Pinchers Bottom Feeders grow
larger mouths and sharks find themselves
developing heightened senses and even
extra hearts these marine animals seem
to undergo virtually no distress and are
free to exit and re-enter the scp's body
at any point initially
scp-4568-2 was believed to be the
peaceful one of the pair both serpents
seem to become active at the same time
while on land
scp-4568-1 would wreak havoc with
magnitude 7 earthquakes in major
metropolitan areas the sea Serpent's
function was less well understood
employing resonant frequencies and
vibrations this SCP was able to give its
watery body a distinct form as it rose
up from the ocean and towered above the
waves in order to maintain its shape and
control its movements this SC CP
employed a huge amount of energy however
the foundation quickly observed that it
was rarely able to maintain its form for
very long as soon as the sea serpent
rose out of the water its mountainous
twin would begin to move sending Tremors
around the world that disrupted the
frequency needed for
scp-4568-2 to remain animate exhausted
and unable to maintain its shape the sea
serpent would fall into another period
of dormancy gliding lazily through the
oceans but this dormances suited the
foundation without the constant seismic
Tremors researchers could work fast two
operating bases were set up to monitor
each as CP two mirrored bases with
mirrored teams in constant communication
with one another as soon as one team
made a discovery it was conveyed to the
others and vice versa one operating base
was set up high in the Andes Mountains
specifically designed to be as
earthquake proof as possible capable of
which standing earthquakes up to 9.9
magnitude meanwhile in the South Pacific
Ocean an underwater Research Center was
built just above the seabed with regular
vessels drifting out into the unknown to
gather whatever data they could about
the great SCP
several early findings stood out firstly
scp-4568-1 appeared to have a very
different internal structure from its
twin researchers initially assumed that
the creature would be largely composed
of Earth minerals and rock as its
exterior appearance suggested however
scans of its body indicated the presence
of what can only be assumed to be
artificially created components great
gears resembling Clockwork structures
and even rudimentary circuitry were
present throughout the creature's body
the function or origin of these gears
has yet to be determined especially as
there is no evident way that their
movement corresponds to the autonomy and
movement of the serpent itself the far
more striking Discovery however game
when the SCP Foundation discovered a way
to communicate with the two beasts ultra
low frequency waves capable of traveling
vast distances even light years were
discovered to be emitted from the two
serpents heads at intermittent period
the foundation had to develop some of
the largest antenna ever created to pick
up these frequencies and interpret the
data coming through them what they found
were two twins locked in a fierce debate
about the fate of humanity and the
universe itself it was only then that
the motivations of these two serpents
started to make sense in 2010 almost as
soon as the foundation was able to tap
into the frequency they were contacted
directly by
scp-4568-1 Foundation I know that you
can hear me I will not apologize for my
actions I know that I am the reason that
millions of your kind face their demise
I know your pain and I feel it too but I
shall never apologize for it I simply
ask you to listen to myself and to my
word cannot be translated you are
curious you can be patient exercised
effect and you may one day understand
and listen the foundation did efforts to
contain or destroy the two serpents were
put on the back burner instead
Foundation agents prioritize spreading
disinformation across South America and
Beyond about the source of these
earthquakes the two serpents are far too
large and far too powerful to overcome
or contain instead the foundation
prioritized the use of amnestic drugs
disinformation and the creation of
Fringe conspiracy groups to discredit
any claims of the Serpent's respective
existences meanwhile some of the most
senior leadership figures in the
foundation were and still are locked in
a fierce debate as to what to do with
the twin serpents by listening to the
communication between the two scps the
foundation discovered that
scp-4568-2 is intent on wiping out the
entire human race the only thing that
has prevented it from being able to do
so thus far has been the existence of
the other serpent every time that
scp-4568-2 begins to mount an attack on
Humanity its land-bearing twin triggers
enormous earthquakes to disrupt its
progress but why would the sea serpent
want to destroy the human race as
Foundation generals gathered in the deep
sea operations base
scp-4568-2 came to the observation
window to look them in the eyes as it
told them I am sure you can see it how
your world dies a little bit more every
day mostly by your own hand no you
poisoned the oceans tamed the rivers
black in the skies you do not need
angels of death to destroy your world
but there is something else I see it in
the bottom of your eyes something
Unforgettable unconceivable
Madness and impossible colors do you
think I will let you dry the rest of the
world down with yourselves do you think
I will leave this world my world to Die
In Flames it seems your world and it
comes in fives since this Revelation the
foundation has poured countless hours
and resources into trying to identify a
cosmic threat for well over a decade
many of the smartest scientists the
world has to offer have looked to the
night sky scanning for this impossible
color this shroud of Madness but to no
avail some within the foundation believe
the serpent is lying trying to make up
an excuse to justify its genocide but
information from
scp-4568-1 seems to confirm everyone's
worst fears your minds burn bread
Foundation all of humanity shines from
this rock like a candle in a dark room
it sees you an idea exists only because
something thought of it have you ever
considered how such terrible Concepts
could have been given for him what kind
of atrocious mind could even think about
it humans cannot conceive the colorless
green what if you are playing into this
creature's hands there appears to be an
underlying implication that ideas are
the source of power somehow this
colorless green this unimaginable Cosmic
threat seems to be a monstrous idea
incarnate but whose idea Humanities
there is a deep lore that the two
serpents discuss with one another one
that makes little sense even to this day
to the foundation they talk of gods and
goddesses deities of Flesh of Steel and
gears and of the fives quite what these
creatures are if they are even creatures
at all is a mystery to the foundation
researchers have not discovered a way of
communicating back with the two serpents
directly attempts to mimic their
language or transmit signals asking
questions to them have largely been
ignored instead they address you
identity and the foundation as a whole
seeming to take the view of the human
race as being a collective hive mind one
that they are evidently able to tap into
the pair seem uninterested in informing
us as to exactly what this threat is or
explaining who the gods and goddesses
are perhaps they assume we know these
things already or more likely they
believe that our Consciousness is not
yet capable of perceiving the scale and
depth of the concepts that they are
debating what is clear however is their
shared understanding that if Humanity
were to be eliminated the candle was to
be blown out this Cosmic threat would
pass by the pair have names trenten is
the land serpent while remaining dormant
much of the time in an enormous Cave
System beneath the Andes Mountains this
serpent seems Keen to help the
foundation in some way kaikai the sea
serpent is intent on sacrificing the
human race for a greater good one far
beyond our understanding speaking to the
foundation in the Andes Mountains
fronten gave a short speech that served
both as encouragement and a terrible
warning of the darkness to come the
the something I Like About You
Foundation about the mankind while it is
easy to just take the simplest path to
just give up there will always be some
among you who refuse this path who do
the right thing maybe not all of you are
this strong but I can see it in your
methods those so-called containment
procedures there will always be someone
who stands up against the dog even if it
takes a thousand million years to emerge
Victorious maybe you can stop the thief
after all ideas can be killed with
better ideas even if it takes a thousand
million years now go check out
scp-2317 the Devourer of Worlds a door
to another world and scp-001 the world's
gone beautiful